Let's Go full screen
so let's go over to the normal distribution
now.
lots of
different mathematical Concepts lots of
mathematical notation
Now I want us to jump to this nor distribution because
it will.
Expose us to a number of important Concepts
and statistics.
in one
in one goal
Okay, so we will learn different things. We will
learn so many things by looking at one example of the
normal distribution.
Which of course once you learn what these ideas are
then you can apply them to learn.
or every other
probability distribution out there
okay, so if
A lot of this is new to you and alien to you. Don't worry.
First we will immerse ourselves into the notation and
then we will break down.
The mathematics so we understand every single the meaning
of every single character. That's my intention.
so
here's an example.
By the way for your reference, these examples
are exercises are apart
from a book.
If you want to know what that book is so you can read it
more yourself. It's it's at the end of the slide which will be
shared.
at the end of this Workshop
But let's look at this example.
Let's see how normal distribution can help us solve
some statistical problems.
It says that the return on our Diversified
Investment Portfolio is normal distributed.
What is the probability that the
return?
Is within one standard of its mean value.
So before I
continue
with the
with a probability distribution
Especially in the context of finance and
investment and risk.
you want
to have a small standard deviation
for that particular private distribution the smaller
the standard deviation. The closure will
be towards the mean.
Which means that?
You are less likely to have variation and less
variation means less risk.
Okay, just to give you some context.
Here. Do you want to see the reason they're concerned with
the probability being within one standard deviation is because again,
they want minimum risk.
So what is a probability that the return is within one standard deviation of its mean
value. This question can be asked without either knowing Mrs.
So we don't need to know these.
With the we don't need to know these variables as long
as the distribution is known to be normal. In other
words. The answer is the same for any normal distribution.
Okay.
so